[Music]
[Applause]
uh the new orleans saints have picked
their starting quarterback jameis
winston jeff duncan covering the team
new orleans times picayune sports
columnist uh let me start with that
season opener given the weather and we
still have some time here is there uh
contingency plans if the saints can't
host the packers that opening weekend
jeff
yeah dan they're working on that right
now i mean the situation is so fluid as
you can imagine in new orleans uh the
power outage is catastrophic the entire
city is still out of power
and so there's so many other priorities
right now in the city
beyond the football game and we just
talked to sean payton this morning
they look like the saints are going to
set up shop in the dallas fort worth
area for at least the next month or so
and he mentioned that they've even
looked into possibly
playing their home games over in dallas
at at stadium i think that's one of the
ideas they're knocking around but
there's just so many moving parts here
they're trying to make
roster cuts today and get players out of
there and they've got families
members all in the hotel and they're
gonna have to move hotels so it's uh
it's a crazy situation very
unprecedented well as you mentioned that
they're masters at some how finding a
way to figure these things out and and
so is this city uh how is this city
prepared now as opposed to previous
hurricanes
well the 16 billion dollar hurricane
protection levy system
certainly is the biggest difference i
mean that withstood all the ida
floodwaters and that was really one of
the great success stories of this storm
unfortunately the power outages have
become a crisis
and i don't know i was asking some of my
colleagues this morning as a major
american city
ever been without power for two to three
weeks i i don't know we're trying to
find that out we've certainly have
become accustomed to these unprecedented
uh natural disaster situations and and
the saints
understand this from what they went
through in katrina
you can come back to play a football
game but what are the living conditions
there's not going to be any schools open
there's going to be no health care
hospitals are already taxed with the
covid situation
there's no running water or power uh you
don't want to be in those conditions and
so sean payton and mickey lewis the
general manager they've been through
this a bunch of times and i think they
understand the best thing they can do to
find a safe
harbor somewhere else and operate from
there
but dallas is going to be the home away
from home
maybe for a month and then
they they may just
commit to playing the home games in
dallas
that's what it sounds like they looked
into oxnard california sean's experience
with the cowboys that's where they have
their training camp we've been watching
that on hard knocks
that's set up perfectly
to house a football team there's a hotel
right there it's just too far
logistically for the saints to travel
their first
four games are all on the east coast of
the united states so it made no sense to
fly back and forth to the west coast
they looked at the greenbrier where they
had training camp
from 2014 to 2016 in west virginia there
were some logistical issues there so it
just makes sense for them to set up shop
and who knows this could work out better
and they could get back quicker so
for them being close by in a short plane
ride um you know is certainly makes more
sense right now and i have to say this i
mean this is a huge i know none of us
are going to feel sorry for nfl owners
they've got deep pockets but this is an
extraordinary expense for
the saints organization having to put up
family members and and two to 300 people
in a hotel for at least a month
how patient is sean payton going to be
with jameis winston
that's a great question i'm eager to see
it he insists dan that
his offense is more user-friendly more
quarterback friendly
than the offenses jameis winston has
played in the past we're going to find
out we're going to see if
jameis can avoid those bad jameis
uh mistakes and it's not just the
turnovers it's it's sacks he holds the
ball much longer than drew brees did i
think some of those things
all of us are going to find out
including sean payton in the season once
they start operating against real nfl
defenses
is taysom hill the backup quarterback
like what what is his designation on the
on the roster is he back to being just
an all-purpose player is somebody else
the backup quarterback
i think the way it'll play out
is
taste of if a long-term injury affected
jameis winston taysom would be the
starter but in a game
during the week when tateson has been
operating
uh preparing to be the the
jack-of-all-trades gadget guy he would
not come into the game as the backup it
would probably be some whoever that is
ian book or trevor simeon we don't know
yet who's going to be the backup but
then if it were long term
taysom would go back to leading the team
the way he did last year
jeff thank you i know you got a lot to
write about and uh certainly a lot to
explore here over the next month and uh
hopefully that city is uh able to bounce
back uh it's resilient but um going
through it again thanks for joining us
jeff
yeah thanks for having me on dan
appreciate it that's jeff duncan new
orleans times picayune sports columnist